Nicolas Cage joestar's
Nicolas Cage and ty Sheridan what this
movie is about is a man who basically
he's like a foreman you know you go to
him you work for him he runs this
operation that cuts down trees to clear
the way for various places that are
gonna be planting there and everything
they poisoned the trees because they're
weak and old and they cut them down
they're kind of it a little bit of a
legal gray area where it's always kind
of like I know if this is legal but
whatever it's fine because we're in the
middle of crap stayin nowhere literally
like this film looks as if it just takes
place in a dumpster somewhere and along
comes this younger kid played by ty
Sheridan from mud and he asks Nicolas
Cage for a job and he gives it to him
and they bond and along the way some
really serious stuff happens with this
boy's extremely abusive father he's
trying to provide for his family this
young kid and this father is in the way
and Joe is very bothered by that he's a
man who is filled with seething rage
from things that have happened to him in
his past and he's always trying to hold
that in and because of this we get an
amazing return from Nicolas Cage and one
of his best performances he's ever given
I'm so happy to tell you that I've been
a fan of Nicolas Cage forever even when
he is in movies that admittedly are
terrible I still enjoy watching him on
screen he makes them more entertaining
he makes a movie more entertaining even
if it's a terrible movie like I saw that
movies stolen such a bad movie but I
enjoyed watching Nicolas Cage act
because he's awesome he's Nicolas Cage
he's Nicolas Cage okay just saying his
name makes me smile but I can finally
say this is truly a great performance he
still has it in him to be fantastic in a
film this is his best performance since
matchstick men which i think is a very
underrated movie he's extremely subdued
here he is so so quiet and controlled
and then when it explodes it's
incredible he is so terrific in this
film young ty Sheridan also pulling out
another great performance after mud
which is a very similar movie you know a
boy meets someone who's a father figure
that he doesn't really have and it's
sort of like in a rural town and there
are definitely similarities I would say
muds a little bit of a better
a little bit more of a focused film than
Joe is but Joe impressed me on so many
levels because of the way it's snuck up
on me
it sets up characters and it sets up
this town they're in so well that it all
feels incredibly real and no one feels
as if they're acting every character in
this film feels as if they're just there
this is where they exist and there are
no cameras around and that is something
that is so authentic about this movie
and the way it eventually got so
dramatic and so powerful really
surprised me and kind of shocked me
because I couldn't believe how invested
I was in these characters lives and the
way the film decided to take these
characters as it explored the bond
between this man and the young kid ty
Sheridan and Nicolas Cage are fantastic
in this film but there's a performance
in this film that's extremely special
for one reason this is guy named Gary
Poulter not an actor he was actually a
homeless man who was pulled off the
street from David Gordon Green the
director this guy gave an incredible
performance in this movie and according
to filmmakers that is him he's not even
performing he actually is an alcoholic
homeless man who has a lot of problems
with that the tragedy of this is that
after filming he was found dead its face
down in the water and I didn't know
about that as I watched this movie I was
soem I was like man this guy is an actor
this guy is so good and then when I read
that I was like that is one of the
saddest things I've ever read in my life
and I guess it's a great epitaph to him
because he truly is great in this film
and he played a character that just it
was him you know when you watch the
movie knowing that knowledge it's very
sad the film has a lot of really great
ways of linking things with visuals from
the beginning to the end which I won't
spoil character of Joe is very
interesting he has a lot of great
backstory you really care about him as a
person because you start to really feel
the desperation of the not-so-great life
that he's led and Nicolas Cage just
owned every moment of his screen time as
I said the film sneaks up on you it
starts and you're setting up these
characters in the location and you're
really getting into it and then all of a
sudden it just reveals itself for this
very very dark drama and I thought that
it handled everything very beautifully
it is a bit of a slow burn but once it
gets started it's definitely worth your
time great performances interesting
story very good direction I'm gonna give
Joanne a - this year is awesome I have
given three a - as already this weekend
how crazy is that this is looking to be
one of the best years in cinema we've
had recently I have give
a lot of a grades already and it's only
April I'm extremely pleased with 2014 so
far if you guys have seen Joe it is
available on VOD today I downloaded it
at home through my u-verse cable
whatever thingy majiggy and I got to
watch it in my living room which was
awesome I hope you guys check it out
thanks so much for watching guys and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck with nice
[Music]